hello and welcome to the spectators
alternative conference sponsored by
barclays
with this autumn's political conferences
moving online the spectator has brought
together
politicians academics think tanks and
members of the public
to discuss a year that's fundamentally
changed britain and
where we go from here for the next three
days spectator tv will be hosting over
20 panels
in conversation events and live podcasts
with topics
ranging from healthcare to the labor
market from trade
to technology our future relationship
with the eu
and of course the effects of covets on
virtually every aspect of our lives
today's line-off kicks off with a
morning of economics
kindly sponsored by barclays and the
spectators kate andrews will be cheering
the panel on the economic recovery from
cobit 19
featuring the financial secretary to the
treasury jesse norman
then katie bowles will host a panel on
the future of british trade and
globalization
with liz truss this afternoon we've got
a panel on the nhs
and kovitz sponsored by msd and
featuring simon stevens the chief
executive of the nhs
we'll discuss the green revolution
sponsored by drax with the conservative
mp
and former business advisor to the prime
minister andrew griffith
and to cap things off i'll be speaking
to my former colleague now the
equalities minister
kemi baiden about the conservatives
equalities agenda
and how to handle the culture wars now
in between these panels we're going to
have a special
live podcast from our coronomics series
and several panels hosted by some of
britain's leading think tanks
now you the audience watching this
you'll be able to submit questions to us
during each panel and put your thoughts
and ideas to britain's leading
politicians
and thinkers as said you can watch all
of these sessions for free
today simply by going to tv.spectator
dot co dot uk but before we turn to the
public policy debates let's get a
political update from the spectator's
deputy political editor
katie balls so katie here we are
gathered in london not sure the city is
going to be locked down by the time we
leave it
today and over the road in parliament
the conservatives look like
having a rebellion on their hands with
renewal of the
coronavirus act as it stands now so
what can we expect and how difficult
could things get
the government yeah um it's becoming a
rather regular refrain which is
it's looking like it's going to be a
tricky week for boris johnson
and i don't know when that hasn't been
the case for a while but
uh you mentioned a few of the things
coming up the track you saw the
front page of the times today talking
about what
effectively sounds like a circuit break
the idea that boris johnson's
previously dismissed at least in the
short term so almost a social lockdown
where
you can't see your friends people
outside your other household you can't
really go out for dinner
but you can go to school and you can
probably go to work if you really have
to
otherwise work from home i think in
terms of when we might expect to see
these changes
there's always been a sense in
government that you need to give
all these changes such as the rule of
six things like that
about two weeks to get to see the effect
it's having if it's meaning the rates
are changing
so really we wouldn't actually expect to
have anything that grasped this week
however it's very clear that there is
concern in number 10 about the direction
the numbers going in
and specifically on london you have the
london mayor sadiq khan
who's pushing for tougher restrictions
and has been for some time so
while i don't think it's a dead set i
think that's why we might get something
ahead of this idea of the review in
three weeks which is probably what we
hear more about if you're looking at
as far as precedence and then i think if
we go to the house of commons
boris johnson has a real problem on his
hands with his own mps we heard from
graeme brady last week on spectator tv
the week in 60 minutes and ultimately
there was a rebellion coming up the
track
at the moment it seems that boris
johnson is on course for a commons
defeat
however he could be saved because the
speaker may not pick the amendment
but this is all about number 10 and the
government's ability to make decisions
on coronavirus
about consulting mps a block of mps
this is tory mps and some labor wants
the commons to have more powers and the
question is
do they get the chance to have that this
week or is that ran that tension going
to continue for weeks to come
right so you're saying the speaker might
not actually call the amendment now
that's a bit strange
given that the amendment is one fairly
crucial to our democracy
which is whether the government is
allowed to keep on passing laws without
parliament's approval parliament
gave its approval relatively well at the
beginning of the pandemic
in what was genuinely an emergency now
things are moving as a far more normal
rates people are having debates and
parliaments all over europe so
why why do we think this wouldn't be
chosen now yeah
i think as you just say a lot of mps
feel as though we've moved past the
emergency stage of coronavirus
so why are there emergency powers if as
the chances seem to suggest last week we
are now
living with coronavirus the economy has
to change as a result
is that a prolonged year-long emergency
or is this actually the new normal sorry
sorry to use that dreaded phrase
and i think part of the reason for this
though is when it comes to the amendment
there are questions over its legal force
and where it even passes why lindsay
hoyle may not select
it and so i think it comes down to
ultimately
uh commons procedures and so much as you
know his personal liking for coronavirus
right and so but right now if his
amendment passes then we can expect
not quite back to the brexit days but
every single thing the government does
will be debated
i guess the idea of the rebels is that
that will put that will put um
that will put the policies back up to
public scrutiny
that rather than have and messer's witty
and balance come over to present
slides for us they'll be able to make a
better stronger case so
the argument of the rebels is that
they're actually helping the government
by
improving the quality of decision making
because sunlight is the best
disinfectant that might get rid of some
of the
um wrong assumptions because we have
seen for example the government
and use hospital data categorizing as a
cobra death something that turns out
not to have been a covert death that's
the sort of thing that's got them
worried
it's not so much is that right isn't it
is it the case that they're not so much
we're not worried about the direction of
policy
just that right now you might get errors
creeping in
simply because the parliamentary
scrutiny filter has been switched off
yeah well i mean i think these mps
believe they're being helpful i'm not
sure number 10 thinks they're being
particularly helpful
um the chief whip is going to be meeting
with some today to try and get them to
change course
also offer assurances but i think
ultimately there are a few things
as you say there is a sense amongst some
tory mps that because there is not a
proper debate going on
and you have written about fraser's
black box you know diplomacy in a way
and that means that things do fall
through the cracks you have mistakes
things that if you actually had a
parliamentary debate it's not necessary
that steve baker would be able to go
through all the data
but it would mean that more people were
in the conversation and listening
and things would be flagged if you look
at the mps backing the brady amendment
what's quite striking is
these aren't just lockdown skeptics on
the libertarian wing of the party
you have many one nation tories like
damien green now
i don't think all these people back in
this amendment would agree
on the next steps in coronavirus some
would want tighter restrictions some
would want
few restrictions but what they all agree
on is that right now having a very small
body of people making the decisions
is not healthy and just finally i think
if you're looking at the various
restrictions if this does
get selected and then goes through
number 10 can't get these mps to walk
back
and all the signs are that kierstama's
labor would probably go with this
if their own amendment doesn't pass it
is going to be
interesting because we have a situation
where when we're talking about things
like a circuit break
i think that there is limited appetite
on the tory
back benches for anything that comes
close to a national lockdown
and when you're talking about a circuit
break which is effectively a minimum of
two weeks so a lot of businesses that
are just starting to get back on their
feet closing
i think you could get strong opposition
now tory mps might be opposed
some touring p's will support it but
then that goes over to labour almost to
say well
kirsten you have to actually start
taking very active positions on all of
this
now some of the things we're going to be
discussing in the spectator conference
this week
is what was referred to in the old days
as politics
right now it's been covered cobit i
guess
uh one of the things that the the rebels
are arguing
is that politics doesn't need to go back
in normal they're really important
questions
about the economy about energy even
about
environmental regulation that if you
delay these conversations
it will be to the detriment of the
country so is that part of the argument
that
they're basically they're pushing for
the government to stop being
based a covert only response they're
pushing for the nhs to be
effectively the national coburn service
and to push us back towards
the kind of topics we're just going to
be discussing today
yeah i think there is part of it and i
think there is a sense that if you look
back to a few months ago so
in the spring when we were in that
intense period
there was no one in government working
anything but coronavirus
if as someone in number 10 said to me at
the time and i asked you know what else
is going on
and you know if anyone is working on
something else they're doing something
wrong
there is a sense this government has to
focus on other things now
but also what these tory mps are quite
worried about
is that we have a situation where the
chancellor is obviously
for seeing a change in their economy to
adapt to living with coronavirus
now that means that all of a sudden
there are big policy decisions
which coronavirus is influencing which
go into domestic policy areas things
that we're going to be talking about at
this conference
and i think they want to be part of that
conversation because if you're talking
about what's going to prosper
in the post-coronavirus age or even the
living with coronavirus age
that is not just an emergency decision
and that's a decision where lots of
uh conservative values you know there's
a debate that needs to be had and i
think that's one of the big things
driving this
can we talk a bit about the relationship
between the treasury and number 10. now
the whole point
of rooty sunny becoming chancellor was
that sasha javid was saying look i this
is an outrageous
um affront to my independence as
chancellor because boris johnson wanted
to have
teams split between the the treasury and
number 10.
now the idea is that rishi tsunak was
supposed to be far more on board
with boris johnson than sasha javid was
but already if you pick up the papers
you're beginning to see
um rishi soon betrayed anyway
as not quite being m the lockdown
skeptic but far more
on that wing than number 10 we hear for
example that it's normally rishi sunny's
voice which is
persuading the prime minister to hold
off not to implement
the full lockdown measures which is um
sage committee advisers
are asking him so in the next session
when we get um
jesse norman the financial secretary of
treasury discussing the
can we expect from him a sort of more
focus on the broader aspects of the
economy i mean can we see
tension growing in other words between
number 10 and number 11.
so i'm not sure if it's tension yet but
uh i don't think it has been unnoticed
that if you pick up the papers they tend
to be quite negative about boris johnson
and quite positive about rishi sunik
and i think that when you speak to tory
mps um by the odd one
and they tend to have more praise for
rishi zunak than boris johnson
there is a sense the treasury has been
the one blocking a lot of the more
restrictive measures that have been
pondered
and i think that i i've had tory mp say
to be
over on friday that if rishi sunik was
making
the main decisions on coronavirus things
would look very different we would not
be
heading to this you know uh mini
semi-locked and type of arrangement
so i think that also if you look at
rishi's next phrases
last week when he talked about you know
living without fear it definitely seemed
to be
a different script to what boris johnson
was talking about so
i think that they do seem now i think
we're seeing more differences i think
they have been exacerbated
it's clear that the chancellor is always
going to be focused on the economy and
that probably does lead you to one side
of this debate
but i think that this idea that you are
going to
i remember when rishi's unit was first
announced as sergeant jefferson's
successor and everyone said he's going
to be baby chino so
baby chancellor and name only and that
has completely
not proved to be the case and this joint
number 10 number 11 unit
where you have special advisors working
both for number 10
and for the treasury and importantly
approved by number
10. actually they're all very loyal to
rishi and there is a
strong sense that there is a uh rishi
sunac team and a boris johnson team
though just to slightly kill the
wrestlemania before i finish
there was one um over the tory mp what's
up fred
over the last week when they were
putting out all these snazzy graphics
that rishi sweet
uses there was one uh government
minister johnny mercer
he replied saying you know i do want to
share this but can i have one that
doesn't
have just rishi's signature i'd like to
have conservative branding so
not everyone is ledger sure katie thanks
very much indeed well let's go
straight on from that to our first
session of a spectator's virtual
conference today
hosted by my colleague kate andrews with
jesse norman to discuss
the recovery thank you katie
you